hey you guys I'm Lisa from the score
esports now trash-talking has always
been an integral part of competitions
especially East Board just recently
Pelias of any challenger team united
tweeted some not so nice things about
his opponent gold coin united he united
ended up losing to them three two one
so in honor of this incident we are
counting down the top 10 best
trash-talking moment and league of
legends our chart and Reginald like
they've been bashing heads to for every
I made q Semin the sole purpose of being
feel G and you know what it worked
keep it simple keep it clean whenever we
fight industry we LG they're pretty much
a bunch of known in I don't really
respect them I just think they're by far
the worst you know K this is really so
long the wrong way for CLG oh my gosh
double thinking so much versus knocking
from Serafino C outlet filled out three
times with us yes he does
there are three people down here for
philosophy and they just melt him down
the first image is their great route by
ever discus she's in rough form but like
you as one actor getting a toe Chris
goes and finds one right there they're
going to go in on big penalty as well
yeah we immediately bursted evidences
but Chris once again class is in with
the Maelstrom and shows why Kenan has
been such a popular hit championship SK
Telecom K came back to Korea went
perfect season they went through an
entire season champions without losing
the game after the files were over and
they had won a perfect season piglet was
crying because he felt he did not play
well enough well beyond an octoroon
mama's room
really really sad right now about to cry
because I just I played so horribly I'm
very different with how I played and you
can see it and at this this is sigelei
level with our own personal television
will title hang out Yankee get up walk
they get on a communal using with Israel
there's no changes you guys are in a
fantastic mood of course this was the
first big test for you guys coming up on
the stage so what is it what does it
taught you about your skill level and
going up against the top and 18th in the
LCS how strong you think it'd be as far
as I know the only n18 I'm worried about
is cloud 9 the rest are non-existent
especially CLG now this is what happens
when you give dyrus is on Mike
shots fired telling Wisconsin where the
mm saloon is orchid on the tournament a
referral another if any unit on Gator
part of long tom tampatom you don't get
party knee in the Wonderlic Hotspur John
du Pont along the route and a choice
Tina Gribble take I total a wise
decision soon
[Music]
LeMond Hinault okay Kukui naraku
Cheonggye dokuro echoes popularity
terminal okay who knew you need over
alternative name to drink cookin ghetto
money title vision 2210 screaming huh
want to make the place a library that's
a tall order I'm not sure hey well the
audience here is going to let them do
that Jeff and Juliana's may improve to
Daniel a three-ball Achtung Bonnie
epidemiology conservative use a takeover
it's very - no need now the castle
capable
[Applause]
from Revell
de Tulear on gone and repeating in
capital completely foundations of our
whiskey engine trying to run your motto
Ilana gay she said okay remember
everyone for a logical attorney is I'm
going to ask you about that yesterday
matchup here you're talking about you
guys should have won it you had really
just solid hold on that game what were
your thoughts immediately after that
game when you suffer defeat to CLG
honestly is a fluke they're not the
better team not even close
if they were the better team they
wouldn't have been down four dragons and
eleven KS end of the game but we mess up
we mess up one teamfight and we lose the
game so they can have the set but if we
meet them in playoffs I'm sure we'll be
some mess there as well he did have some
fun tweets this whole atonement as well
Jensen is certainly a character but he
just cannot wait to play fake oh that's
it oh he said he can't wait to clap a
customer says thank you mom you see the
most expensive playing a speaker because
he's I guess I heard the most respected
Molina's of everyone so saying guess
them it's like if you want to prove
yourself you have to be faker and that's
like one opportunity I get so wrong
again does have something fake it's
getting it the Sun slanted Becky flack
this board and five o'clock go slowly
this is just sex on you
said he saw you eat them out he saw at
least on his screen and at that point
you need to know Peter for his kidney
duty to Polk County nine to four day
five here and suffice
it's relay he flushed his stuff and they
all he still killed in its own charges
not even rose from fake just completely
shutting out Jensen put the Nexus open
I'm going to try and close the game
sneaky takes out two then looking at
right back here but Fang takes out
sneaky to return Jake just get a fall
down a fan gets a double speedy off
sources how good is it to get a
pentakill of the LCS or some LCS
all-stars it take me if you lose your
pluses North America
everyone else's trash and here on the
shelf is trash so these were our picks
for the top 10 best trash-talking
moments in League of Legends do you
agree or disagree with our list let us
know in the comments below thanks for
watching
if you want more great content be sure
to hit that subscribe button